European Union transport ministers are
discussing ways to increase the
availability of alternative fuels across
the EU to help stimulate demand for
clean power the aim is to reduce
Europe's dependence on fossil fuels
improve energy security and cut
greenhouse gas emissions from sources
like Motor Vehicles the proposal
includes issues like the minimum number
of recharge points for electric cars in
EU countries or requirements for natural
gas and hydrogen refueling stations in
member states where such refueling
possibilities exist in cities the idea
would be to encourage more to be built
in outlying areas so that clean vehicles
can be used throughout the country
putting in place sufficient
infrastructure and setting common
standards across Europe are considered
crucial to boosting market demand for
alternative fuels at the same time the
move would stimulate demand plus
research and development in consultation
with Member States the European
Commission hopes to publish in the near
future national targets for this clean
energy infrastructure with the aim of
having it all in place by 2030